hi everyone good morning I am well aware
that I am standing between you and lunch
so I will only go 30 minutes overtime
cool so but actually I know that I'm
standing between you and lunch we'll try
to get you out of here early also leave
some time for questions with that let's
go ahead and get started today's talk is
basic C 4 is not encryption a better
story for kubernetes secrets
my name is Seth I'm an engineer at
Google I've been at Google about two and
a half years now
prior to that I worked at Hacha Corp for
four and a half years prior to that I
worked at chef prior to that no one
cares please laughs it makes me feel
good Cole so there's gonna be lots of
live demos there's gonna be kind of
switching between slides and terminals I
hope everyone's okay with that before we
do that sorry I have to I have to like
kill your mojo now because before we do
that I have to set some background
context throughout this talk I'm gonna
say some words and I want to make sure
that we're all on the same page when I
say those words because you might have a
different context or connotation the
first one is a secret when I today
secret for the context of this talk I'm
specifically talking about like an
application-level secret or a machine
level secret and that's gonna be like an
API key or credential or a password or
like a you know some upstream credential
that's used by the application at build
time or runtime in order to perform some
function specifically I'm not talking
about like a credit card number or a
passport number or social security
number there's no reason you couldn't
apply these principles to those types of
Secrets but that's not specifically what
we're talking about so now that we're on
the same page of what is a secret we
have to ask ourselves a really obvious
question which is why do we care why do
we not use public Twitter for all of our
secret storage there's an API it's
easily accessible everyone else will be
able to use it well there's a few key
reasons why we have to protect secrets
the first is that they're an incredibly
attractive target for hackers secrets
are often protecting something that's
why they're a secret because they're an
attractive target for hackers they're
often also leaked in public repositories
or storage buckets if we look at a lot
of the recent data breaches that have
occurred especially in the operations
community they've been a result of like
a
frig bucket that hasn't had the proper
eye and permissions it was left publicly
exposed or an engineered a company
accidentally committed their access keys
or their credentials to a public github
repository or source source control
repository and someone was able to
escalate privilege and then the third
reason which is why it's such an
attractive target for hackers is that
they often include overly broad
permissions how many people here work at
a start-up or have ever worked at a
start-up so if you work at a startup
everyone's root there there is no time
to do permissions like you got VC
funding you have a market to get to
everyone gets root and you know like ten
years later all of those original
employees probably still have root in
the system and you know as an
organization's grow and you build like a
traditional IT security practice and you
start doing threat modeling and
tightening down those permissions models
that's great
but in general secrets and credentials
often include overly broad permissions
the first reason as already mentioned is
because it's just easy it's easier to
give everyone access to everything the
second reason is that sometimes we don't
exactly know how to map the low-level
system permissions to the actual
business value that our users or our
engineers are trying to get right how do
you map an SE Linux permission or an API
credential or an iam permission to the
actual engineers responsibilities and
how do they escalate when they need more
permissions and that's you know
incredibly time-consuming so oftentimes
we just forget it
give everyone root it's fine so there
are four key ways in which we can
protect secrets and the first is
actually on the opposite side of it
which is the easiest way to protect
secrets is assume they're going to be
compromised if you have it in your
mental model that if at some point this
secret or this credential is going to be
compromised all of this becomes really
easy and when you put that in your mind
the very first thing that you think of
is auditing if I assume that my
credential is going to be compromised
how can I detect that as quickly as
possible and that's where auditing and
logging come in so log every login log
every access of a credential log every
super credential and if you're really
sophisticated you can feed that into
like an anomaly detection system so that
if you know hey
normally these applications request this
credential between 9 a.m. and 5 p.m. to
do some credit-card processing all of a
sudden we see that this credential is
being requested at 2:00 in the morning
that might be an anomalous pattern
something that we want to raise with our
site reliability engineers our security
team to take a look at the second way
that we want to protect secrets is the
very obvious one and the bulk of this
talk which is encryption we want to
encrypt secrets at rest so when they're
put on the file system or in memory and
we want to encrypt them in transit using
something like TLS or a TLS on top of
that with you assume that your
credentials are going to be leaked or
penetrated or stolen in some way shape
or form rotation is key we need to be
rotating our credentials as much as
possible not just our own internal
credentials like TLS certificates but
also upstream API keys and certificates
and access keys and lastly we have to
isolate where our secrets are stored
from where our secrets are accessed and
this is incredibly important because if
we store our secrets in the same place
that they're accessed we reduce and
attackers requirements to gain access to
our system
all of that being said I only have 40
minutes so we're really going to zoom in
on the encryption side of things now
disclaimer I'm not saying the other
three aren't important in fact I would
argue that auditing is probably the most
important it's just a really boring talk
so instead we're gonna focus on
encryption and there's depending on who
you ask
3 or 4 layers of encryption in you know
today's software world we have things
like hardware level encryption or
machine level encryption file system
encryption this is like apples file
vault or Windows BitLocker those types
of things and then as we move further up
the stack we have service level
encryption and application layer
encryption and but what I specifically
want to talk about and the one that's
relevant to kubernetes is application
layer encryption so application layer
encryption is a cryptographic pattern
that is applied at the earliest possible
step of an applications lifecycle the
idea is that I'm gonna get a credential
my application is going to receive a
credential and it has a big bubble
around it and within that bubble the
secret or the credential exists in plain
text and if the secret ever leaves that
bubble it's encrypted before it exits
the
bubble that includes logging systems
other micro services a front-end web UI
whatever it might be the secret only
ever exists within that bubble and that
bubble is defined by your threat model
right I can't define that bubble for you
because it exists only within the
context of that bubble we get very
granular permissions when we look at
something like file system level
permissions again like File Vault or
BitLocker there's one key that encrypts
the entire hard drive for the entire
system so if an attacker is able to
brute force that one key they have
access to everything it's kind of like a
bank vault where once you get in you can
just steal all of the money when we move
further up the stack and we look at
something like application layer
encryption every secret can be encrypted
with its own unique encryption key and
we can couple that with something like
file level insist a file of a file level
encryption or final system level
encryption which gets you like yes
there's one key that gets you into the
bank vault but then once you're in the
bank vault every safety security deposit
box has its own key right and that's
kind of the metaphor I'd like you all to
think about it's like yeah there's one
key that unlocks the data but then the
data itself is encrypted with its own
unique key and sometimes we have
multi-party authentication or
multi-party systems like Shamir secret
sharing in order to actually unlock that
data and one of the most important parts
about application layer encryption is
that it protects the data as it moves
throughout the system so whereas you
traditionally have like an encrypted
piece of data that encrypted piece of
data is encrypted with a key and
hopefully as it moves throughout the
system it remains encrypted with
application layer encryption again you
define that bubble and even if you're
not using neutral TLS between your
services which you definitely should
application layer encryption will
protect those data even if it's
transmitted over say a public wire
because it's encrypted before it leaves
your application ok so that brings me to
kubernetes as indicated by the four very
sad faces on this slide
I love kubernetes I don't necessarily
love the defaults kubernetes is insecure
by default so how many people here run
applications and services on kubernetes
cool I don't know why you'd be here if
you didn't
how many people run kubernetes
themselves meaning you're not using like
a cloud provider you're running on like
VMware OpenStack or something like that
cool by default when you run coop Codel
create secret or you use the API to
create a kubernetes secret that secret
is stored in plain text in at CD yet CD
is kubernetes like file system basically
it's a back-end datastore it's
distributed but you can think of it like
a file system and you put all these are
back permissions in front of it right
you're like oh it's a secret only these
people can access that only this
namespace can access it even during
these times but at the end of the day if
an attacker has access to the underlying
filesystem at CD they have access to all
of your secrets in plaintext it doesn't
matter what namespace they're in or what
are back permissions you put on them now
I do have to note that if you're
operating kubernetes through like a
cloud provider or a managed service they
may have changed this default behavior
right so like I said if you were to
download kubernetes today open-source
run kou bad man or cops and spin up a
kubernetes cluster you're gonna get the
behavior described on the screen if
you're running on a cloud provider
manage kubernetes they may have altered
that behavior you'll need to check the
documentation you might the the default
might still be this but there might be
like an extra flag or something that you
can pass in that changes this default
behavior so let's look at this visually
because I promise you lots of really fun
animations so throughout the rest of the
presentation we're gonna see like this
little chart here so the credit card is
used to represent our secret data we
have the kubernetes api server and then
we have Etsy D which is like the backend
storage system so we're going to take
our piece of data we're gonna pass our
piece of data to the API server we're
going to run coop cuddle create secret
the kubernetes api server is then i'm
gonna basically for encode that and put
it inside FTD y'all got my base64
encoding joke i see like so this this is
obviously not great because if an
attacker which will represent via the
red raccoon moving forward has access to
an online @ CD cluster a backup of that
CD data file a backup of the file system
of the node that was or container that
was running at sea
or online access to that master VM that
attacker has access to all of your
secrets in plain text
there's no ands ifs or buts I'm not
trying to fear monger
that is literally the state of the world
and you might be thinking to yourself
like no one would ever do this like
clearly no one would ever do this but a
lot of people confuse encoding and
encryption they both start with the
letter e and they have two syllables how
could you not mix them up but when you
confuse encoding with encryption I have
a name for that it's called encryption
encryption is what happens when you
confuse encoding and encryption and if
you're thinking well no one would ever
do this this is terrible no one would
ever publicly expose their ed CD server
for example and there couldn't possibly
be a search engine on the internet that
would show me all of the publicly
exposed at CD servers what does that
link up there Oh weird if you've never
been to shodhan I highly recommend
checking it out it is worth noting that
EDD has uses outside of kubernetes right
it is its own software package the
kubernetes just happens to use is the
back end file store if you spin it up by
default it is also publicly accessible
you can find publicly accessible at CD
servers if you know my friend told me
that they went to that website and found
like over a hundred thousand of them and
of those hundred thousand publicly
exposed Etsy D servers about 80,000 of
them my friend told me were containing
kubernetes secrets in plain text now
those could be development clusters
where like you actually don't care but
it's a pretty high number so let me show
you what this looks like by attempting
to mirror my screen because Apple took
away my ctrl F 1 shortcut cool so here I
have a kubernetes machine thing I'm
running this on a VM and the cloud it's
just a single VM but I have no pods
running but kubernetes is up and running
is this a good font size for everyone
cool cool so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm going to create a secret so I'm
gonna run coupe cuddle create secret
it's gonna be a generic secret will name
it login
from literal our username won't be my
name and our password will be what
should our password be I heard password
strange loop what's over here
in corruption I like that one thanks
Nathan alright so we've created our
secret with two key value pairs a
username and a password so as I said
before when I did this right this is
guarded by our back I could put all the
policies in the world in front of this
but at the end of the day this data is
stored in plain text in SED so if an
attacker has access to NC d or a backup
of NC d they can get access to this data
and let me show you just what that looks
like so I'm using NC d cuddle which is a
command line tool it's pronounced cuddle
there's no other pronunciation to
interact with SED now ICD also has an
API this command line tools actually
just querying the API so you can replace
SED cuddle with curl but then there's a
bunch of custom certificates and I only
have a limited amount of time so we're
running at C D cuddle so we're gonna run
registry secrets default login so I'm in
the default namespace registry is just
where the stuff lives it's a secret and
the name of our secret was login and we
get back this move this up a little bit
so there is a little bit of binary data
in there I like to call binary data
Super Mario Kart item boxes but you can
see that our password is in crashing and
our username is stuff it is like a
little bit weird of a format you can
pipe this to hex stomp and see that
there's like weird line breaks and stuff
in here but right there's our password
and right here is our username so all of
that's in plain text this is also
written to our right ahead log which sed
uses to maintain consistency that is
stored on the file system if you backup
at CD or you backup this file system all
of this data is available in plain text
I'm going to stop rambling hopefully
I've made this very clear to you that
you should not do this cool on mirror
back to Friesen t-shirt so given that
how do we fix it well the way we fix it
is we have to talk about this thing
called envelope encryption how many
people are familiar with envelope
encryption cool this is where the
animations are like really going to
so envelope encryption requires three
pieces of information so we have we're
about to you know have a play and we
have three characters in our cast the
first is our data this is our secret or
credential whatever it's going to be
represented by a blue credit card our
net member of the cast is a red key this
key represents our data encryption key
and that our third member of our cast is
going to be this green key which is our
key encryption key sometimes we call the
red key a deck and sometimes we call the
green key a keck that's really hard to
hear and say so I'm probably just gonna
say the whole word every time so given
that that's the first animation so given
that here's how envelope encryption
works we are going to generate a data
encryption key using system level
entropy 32-bit 64-bit whatever key you
want to generate and we're going to
encrypt our data with that data
encryption key every new piece of data
gets a new key then our key encryption
key the green key will have some
centrally managed system and we use the
key encryption key to encrypt that
unique data encryption key we then take
those two pieces of data the encrypted
data and the encrypted key and we
concatenate them together or to be
determined there's various ways to do
this and we put them in the storage
back-end that might be a file system
that might be a CD that might be a
Twitter post whatever it might be right
and then when we want to reverse this
process we split the data apart again we
then take our data encryption key the
encrypted data encryption key and we ask
the key encryption key to decrypt that
data we now have the plaintext
data encryption key we then use the
plaintext data encryption key to decrypt
the encrypted data which gives us back
the original plaintext data you're
probably thinking to yourself why is
there this red key in the middle why are
you not just using the green key to
encrypt the blue credit card directly
this seems dumb although I liked your
animations thank you for doing that
there's a few key advantages to envelope
encryption the first is that every
single piece of data in our system and
every version of that data in our system
is encrypted with a
Niek high entropy key that's really
great for auditing and compliance
because you can check off so many boxes
on your PCI and various HIPAA compliance
reports with like the ease of a button
also if an attacker is able to brute
force or get access to one of those keys
they don't have access to all of the
data they actually have to brute force
the key for every single piece of data
individually and this exponentially
increases the difficulty at the same
time we have a centrally managed key
system and you'll notice that the number
of key encryption keys is significantly
less than the number of data encryption
keys in fact every piece of data has a
data encryption key every data
encryption key might have like a
logarithmic scale of key encryption keys
and they're centrally managed and you
can revoke a key encryption key at any
time and you've effectively crypto
shredded all of that data because you
can't decrypt the data encryption key
and therefore you can't get access to
the plaintext data and this is why we
have that kind of man in the middle or
person in the middle red key so to
quickly summarize we generate a unique
data encryption key for every data entry
this allows us to crypto Shred we can
revoke those top-level key encryption
keys and revoke all data all at once
this is great if you're working you know
if you have data hosted in you know
hostile Nations or you have customer
data and you need to be compliant for
some reason and a customer says revoke
all my data you can do that without some
huge database operation it also allows
for easy versioning and rotation every
new piece of data gets a new data
encryption key we rotate our key
encryption keys on some fixed interval
like every 30 days or every two weeks
and this also helps with compliance but
it also increases an attackers
difficulty for compromising the system
so why is any of this relevant
well kubernetes one-point-seven actually
introduced envelope encryption into
kubernetes core so envelope encryption
looks a little bit like this so you
specify an encryption provider
configuration in yellow you'll hot that
there was going to be no y Emmel but you
saw kubernetes in the title so i-i don't
know why you thought that so we specify
our encryption provider configuration
this is a first-class kubernetes
construct and it allows us to specify
one or
more encryption keys and kubernetes will
do that envelope encryption so what
you're seeing here in the yamo is the
key encryption key the green key the
top-level key kubernetes is still going
to generate data encryption keys every
time we read every time we write new
data and it will use this key or the
series of keys to encrypt that data as
it's written into the system once we
write out our yamo we then have to pass
an additional option into the kubernetes
api server we have to specifically
specify the encryption provider
configuration file which is just that
yellow file I showed on the previous
screen so what does this look like in
practice well going back to our diagram
from before we have our piece of data
the API server and now we have our
encryption configuration in the middle
we're going to write our plaintext data
to the kubernetes api server and the
kubernetes api server is always going to
see the data in plaintext the kubernetes
api server is then going to delegate to
the encryption configuration the
encryption configuration is going to
perform the envelope encryption of that
data and we now have encrypted data in
at CD so we've successfully mitigated an
attack for an online @ CD cluster go
ahead and expose this at CD cluster
publicly please don't but if you did an
attacker wouldn't have access to the
plaintext secrets they'd still gain a
ton of information about your structure
because they'd know the name of your
secrets and other things but they
wouldn't know the contents of your
secrets we've mitigated a backup of at
CD itself if someone backs up the actual
n CD data file all of the data is
encrypted so we've mitigated against the
original riku n-- the read raccoon now I
pose a question to you which is have we
mitigated against red raccoon number 2
which is if the red raccoon instead of
being you know online the NCD server or
a backup of the HDD data file they
instead have access to a backup of the
file system or online access to the VM
that is running that container or that
service have we mitigated the attack
think about that for a moment the answer
will be after the commercial break there
are a few drawbacks to this approach the
first you have to generate those keys
yourself quick Lucas what's the command
for opener cells
open us a self-generated a 32 bit random
entropy key exactly stack overflow stack
overflow you google it heaven forbid if
the person who has that top answer ever
changes it we're all screwed right
that's hard and it's hard to do it right
and can you guarantee that your system
actually has an appropriate level of
entropy the second drawback is that key
management is your responsibility and
rotation is a manual process that is
incredibly tedious whenever you generate
a new key you have to go into that file
maybe you're using you know chef puppet
ansible or salt to manage that config
file if not someone has to SSH in make
changes to that file save the file
if you mess it up you actually cause
downtime you have to kick the kubernetes
api server which could also introduce
downtime if you're not implementing
retries it's a really tedious process
and then lastly if you work in a highly
regulated industry like medical or
FinTech where you have requirements that
your secrets are encrypted with hardware
security modules or HSMs
you can't do this you can't put an HSM
in yeah mole I've tried so that just
isn't an option has anyone figured out
the real problem though so the real
problem is that that yamo file is stored
in the same place that the secrets are
so if an attacker has access to that VM
or online or a backup of that VMs file
system that yellow file has the keys and
the data that's encrypted with those
keys is in the same place remember back
to the original side when we talked
about isolation we have to separate
we're secrets are stored from where
they're actually access this is
fundamentally why we haven't actually
improved our threat model for any
reasonable degree you've just given an
attacker a really fun laugh because
they're like oh it's so cute they've
encrypted their data and then they put
their keys right here
for me to decrypt their data and that
that obviously isn't a great solution so
we knew this we knew that kubernetes 1.7
was a stepping stone so kubernetes 1.10
builds upon this and introduces the
concept of an encryption provider
configuration for a plugin
so that looks like this it's still Gamal
we tried JSON but the community didn't
like it and instead of specifying the
keys in this file or instead specifying
either an HTTP endpoint or a UNIX socket
where a plug-in lives a third party open
specification plug-in that does
encryption and decryption of these
secrets using the envelope encryption
paradigm or algorithm so that looks like
this we have a new entity in our system
our third party key management service
provider this could be a cloud kms this
could be something like Hasek or vault
this could be anything you want it to be
as long as it's a key management service
that does encryption and decryption
we're going to take our plaintext data
we're gonna give it to kubernetes api
server the kubernetes api server is
going to give it to the encryption
config the encryption configuration is
gonna say cool here plug-in take this
data and do what you do with it I have
written a plug-in that does rot13
because you could do that it's not
really secure but that plug-in is really
really versatile right you can do any
type of encryption or any type of cipher
suites that you want you return the
cipher text data that gets written to at
CD so to reverse the process it's just
the opposite you take the encrypted
cipher text data you give it to the
encryption invigoration which takes it
to the kms provider the kms provider
gives it back which gives you back your
plaintext so now we bring up the
question what if an attacker has access
to the VM have we mitigated this well
we've mitigated an attacker having
access to a backup of the filesystem of
an actual vm because the authentication
which we'll talk about in a bit for
talking to that key management service
is happening at a higher level
we haven't actually mitigated and it's
very difficult to mitigate an attacker
having online access to one of these VMs
and this is where we go back to the
original slide where we talked about
auditing and logging being important
because we're using a third party key
management system we can set quotas and
limits and if all of a sudden we see
that there's a hundred thousand requests
coming from one itd node to decrypt a
ton of data to our key management
service we can restrict or isolate or
rate limit that traffic until we can do
an investigation so we we can't get 100%
medication right security is not binary
it's a scale but we've successfully
mitigated
six of the seven attack vectors through
the plug-in system now you might be
thinking to yourself this sounds hard I
don't want to write a plug in it I don't
even know what language toward the
plugins in are they written in yam oh
there are existing plugins out there so
every major cloud provider has a plug-in
so Google is sure and Amazon all have
plug-ins for their first party key
management services oracle has written
one for a check or vault i've been told
there's one for cyber-ark
but i don't know the link to it if you
find it please give it to me and I'll
update the slide obligatory one slide
vendor pitch I work for Google we can do
this with like three flags moving on
[Music]
this does bring up an interesting
question which is how do you get that
initial secret so we cannot store the
credential for talking to kms on the
file system because if we do we don't
mitigate that attack right an attacker
could just get that credential and talk
directly to the key management service
for an offline attack so this is we're
using a cloud provided a key management
service is really beneficial because you
can delegate Identity and Access
Management to the cloud provider and
then you delegate privilege and access
management to the cloud providers
Identity and Access Management most
cloud providers all major cloud
providers have a way to say that this
instance or this instances identity is
authorized to talk to this particular
service and that authentication lives at
a higher level it lives outside of the
file system or outside of anything that
exists within the context of that
machine it gets authenticated at a
higher level and this is how you get
around that like an initial first secret
problem is by delegating that trust to
the cloud provider and then the last
thing is that we should really be
separating concerns here so instead of
giving you no practice the principle of
least privilege make sure that your NCD
nodes don't even have I am permissions
to talk to canvas at CD itself never
needs permission to decrypt its data
only the kubernetes api server does so
separate those containers apart run them
on different hosts or different node
pools such that those node poles only
have
the most minimal permissions required so
let's take a look at what this
encryption provider configuration
configuration looks like it's actually
called that the encryption provider
configuration configuration click
alright so the first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to show you this
kubernetes manifest
oh no I lied kubernetes PKI and this is
encryption local cotton ok so this is my
community pair server that's a key that
I generated this is live demo please
don't steal it it's fine I'm going to
tear it down in a minute
cool so now I have this encryption
provider configuration let me edit the
kubernetes api server manifests so this
is the kubernetes api server manifest
because i am not really good at typing I
have typed in advanced and this is not
the one I want to uncomment see I told
you I'm really bad at this
all right so I'm gonna uncomment this
encryption provider config flag which is
going to say hey use this local
configuration fun fact they're clapping
fun fact kubernetes watches the file
system so when you save this file the
kubernetes api server automatically
picks up those changes and restarts
that sounds great in theory until you
make a typo and then you're like why is
nothing working ask me how I know so
good I'll get pods - and coop system
people's you've been typing pause this
whole time you know you can run coop
cuddle get an S instead of namespace -
right you can type all those letters out
alright alright we're still waiting for
that to restart all right cool we're
good to go
so while that happened we had downtime
right so remember I talked about on one
of the negative impacts of this is it me
restart that no one could run coop
cuddle get secret no one could run coop
cuddle apply because my API so
was down it was only a few seconds but
it's not super great so I'm gonna run a
coop cuddle delete secret login so I'm
going to delete the login we had before
because that was stored in plain text
Annette CD and then I'm gonna run the
same create secret that we ran before
the exact same command I ran it from my
bash history and I'm gonna run the same
exact @ CD cuddle command and you'll
notice that we get back significantly
more Super Mario Kart item boxes and
this is good because Super Mario Kart
item boxes mean encryption if there's
one thing you take away from this it's
that all so random like foreign
characters also mean encryption in a
terminal so you'll notice that there are
like some English ASCII characters in
here right there is some metadata that
is stored in here that isn't considered
to be secret for example this is telling
kubernetes which key in that list of in
the yellow file was used to encrypt this
data therefore kubernetes knows which
ones to decrypt it with and the version
of the key that was used but in general
all of the data here like all of all of
this data all of the all of the question
marks all of the there's actually a real
item box right there
all of that is encrypted right that's
that's why it's being represented this
way my terminal was like I'll know as I
mentioned though and as we saw I showed
you the encryption key for encrypting
this data so if I had a little bit more
time I could copy that like base64
encode this and and decrypt it and show
you the plaintext is available instead
I'm just going to show you the clapping
- I'm going to show you the KMS
configuration so the KMS configuration
is just a UNIX socket that's listening
locally I need my old key in there so
that I can decrypt old secrets I'm going
to edit the kubernetes api server
manifest so we will switch to our
external kms provider we don't have to
restart the kubernetes api server
because it's so helpful see you look at
downtime
do-do-do-do-do-do maybe I actually broke
it this is the part where I always start
freaking out now okay we're good all
right we're still not quite up we're
pending cool everything else crashed as
intended
as I said you're incurring downtime this
this this whole time
it's really not great the good thing is
once we switch to the kms provider we
never have to do this again because we
can rotate our keys out-of-band
do to do to do alright we don't actually
need Cory DNS we're not resolving
anything so I'm gonna delete the secret
I'm gonna create the secret and I'm
going to read the secret and we get back
the same number of item boxes you'll
notice that we're being encrypted with
the GCP kms plugin this is telling
kubernetes to delegate authentication to
that plugin we have lots of item boxes
as we kind of intended you'll notice the
string is a little bit longer that's
because it's a different cipher suite
that I chose I can also go into like the
Google Cloud console or hit the API and
rotate this key and all new secrets will
get encrypted with the new key all old
secrets can still be decrypted with the
old key all right so I have one last
thing to show you which is what about
volts so what if you're not using a
cloud provider
what if you're on premise and you can't
use a cloud provided km/s or some
third-party kms provider this is where
tools like volt are really useful so
volt is just that third party service
Volt has this really cool thing called a
transit backend or transit secret engine
all of the data goes through volts
transit secret engine and does the
encryption the same way that the
third-party kms provider would do I
promised you multiple live demos so
we're gonna do one more this time I have
to run over to mini cube because I'm
lazy and didn't install volts cool so
I'm going to create a secret in volts I
guess I'll show you this
and create a secret volts so I'm just
running coupe Kota create secret but I'm
doing it on my mini cube context that
has volt installed and configured it's
the same like encryption configuration
file I showed you except the UNIX socket
goes to the Oracle Volt plug-in instead
of the GCP kms plugin and then I'm going
to access the at CD four volts and you
get back the same item boxes that you'd
expect there's a little bit more data in
here so this tells me that like hey
we're using volt this is actually very
critical vault
it's URL encoded basic ste for stuff
that vault uses to identify which
version of the key it use but the data
itself is still encrypted so there again
metadata is not considered part of the
threat model here it's always just the
actual secret data so you will see some
metadata available in plain text and
various places cool so to quickly recap
always use at least two layers of
encryption
I should have emphasized this more like
application layer encryption and
envelope encryption are great they're
not the only solution you should also
still be using file system global
encryption right someone should not be
able to walk into your data center rip
out a hard drive and have access to that
data
rotate your keys and credentials
regularly any time someone joins the
company anytime someone leaves the
company anytime someone goes to the
bathroom rotate your credentials
leverage envelope encryption it's
incredibly scalable it's how a lot of
systems that you're integrating with
actually already work you may not know
it so you should be using it as well and
please protect kubernetes secrets using
an external kms provider thank you all
so much that's my twitter and get home
handle I'll be around
[Applause]